fatty conrad brad pitt scene one take
one
that's the first time i've heard my name
and brad pitt together that is the
closest i have come to brad pitt what's
up gq this is fine points my name is
matty conrad i'm a men's grooming expert
and today we are going to go over the
career evolution of brad pitt and some
of his most iconic hairstyles i've been
working behind a chair in a barber shop
now for over 27 years and i can say with
authority that the most common
photograph that i see behind a chair in
a barber shop is of brad pitt he's
always had a fairly dynamic style he's
gone with a lot of different looks
whether it's growing his hair out really
long for a film like legends of the fall
or interviews of the vampire or cutting
his hair incredibly short for movies
like ocean's 11. brad's always managed
to pick exactly the right look for his
characters
[Music]
so let's start back where mostly it
began for brad in the 90s now we were
coming out of a period in the 1980s
where everything was heavily inspired by
a socal surf and skate vibe and if you
look at the pictures of brad in the
early 90s you can really see the
influence that he had for that very very
tapered out and built out on the sides
so instead of having these really shaped
undercuts things are looking a little
fuller a little wider and this is really
the embodiment of that shape the look
that he created for his character in a
river runs through it was very much a
classic look but something that became
very very popular in the 90s it was sort
of a bullish shape with very tight clean
sides you could look at other shows that
were popular at the time like boy meets
world or like home improvement and you
would see some of the other celebrities
this time the younger guys this youthful
look where they've got this bullish kind
of shape now this looks really good on
brad he can wear this style and this was
the first movie role where he really got
noticed as potential for a leading man
this is really him breaking into that
aspect of the industry and he keeps this
very youthful kind of look
[Music]
as that leading man persona starts to
take hold for brad and as we move a
little further into the 90s the
influence of grunge music starts to take
off and you can see into the 90s as he
kind of starts to grow out a beard for
the first time his hair gets a little
longer has a little bit more of that
cobain influence when he's starting to
do the tuck back and just the longer mop
of hair the role that he was growing his
hair out for was the movie california
where he plays a little bit more of a
darker side so being able to embrace
that with his look i think he leaned
into more of that kind of grunge feeling
to his hair
now post the movie california brad
continued to grow his hair out and the
longer hair was something that became
synonymous with his look especially when
he aced movies like legends of the fall
legends of the fall he played a very
iconic character named tristan who has
become kind of redefined as that
long-haired romantic leading man he gave
it a very pretty attractive look instead
of having to make it look like somebody
that had given up on their looks
continuing with the long hair he then
produces an excellent performance as
essentially a 500 year old immortal
french vampire in interview with a
vampire this is another way in which he
is able to use his look and use the
length of his hair to help embody that
role it's a very transformative thing
for a lot of actors and even still
outside of the scope of acting and
offset they still have a tendency to
embody those vibes and you can see into
the mid-90s brad had a little bit more
of that kind of undead look you know he
had that longer hair and he went and
bleached it out changed out the color of
it and still really embraced that kind
of grunge feel you can see brad is also
embracing kind of that loose baggy
sweater look and so is very very on
point and was something that was talked
about a lot in magazines you'd see them
at a lot of different events with this
and people were just going crazy for it
then came a big transformation
[Music]
now we're in 1995 and brad is booked in
the movie 7 a role for which he
completely changed his look by cutting
his hair very very short at that point
this kind of rough and textured look
called bedhead became very mainstream it
was heavily influenced by punk from the
1970s and early 1980s and it was sought
as kind of a slightly more aggressive
look a lot of guys would come in with
this picture from the movie it really
kicked off the idea of these kind of
bleached out or frosted tips that a lot
of guys were asking for with this really
rough texture now let's just take a
pause here for a second because i think
something needs to be brought up along
his career it's not totally uncommon for
brad pitt to adopt a shockingly similar
style to whoever he's dating let's look
into 1997 where he started dating
gwyneth paltrow her very iconic
hairstyle looked very similar to his
when he was dating jennifer aniston and
she had those weird twisty dread things
even when the rachel haircut for
jennifer anston became completely iconic
his was not trailing too far behind
in the late 90s came possibly one of his
most iconic looks now fight club was an
exaggeration of the shorter style that
he was wearing before that idea of bed
head and that influence of punk but
instead of keeping things short and
contained they were let a little bit
loose and this really suited his tyler
durden character this style was
particularly popular with a lot of
younger guys that would come and wanted
that little rougher that little more
lived in kind of style this is at the
point too where men's hair styling
products started to diversify so that
they could create these really specific
types of textures you weren't just using
mousse and gel anymore suddenly there
was paste and putties and pomades and
all these different products because of
the specificity of how rough and how
interesting these styles looked
in 2001 one of brad pitt's most notable
performances was probably an ocean's 11
where he had a little bit more of a
clean clean-cut look for his character
of rusty who played a bit of a con man
this look for him really really suits
especially the short kind of blonde
frosted out tips the period for frosted
tips usually happened between about the
kind of early 90s until about the early
2000s when they almost entirely
disappeared and guys stopped coloring
their hair all together largely because
to that point we had frosted the tips of
every man on earth sometimes at this
point guys like to change their looks up
too i know that brad at one point had
made a comment in an interview that he
was tired of just feeling like the
hollywood pretty boy and i think that's
probably why he started growing a beard
so this is a little bit tail end for
that but you can still see that brad is
rocking a very short style if i'm being
perfectly honest these are not my
favorite shapes on brad the reason for
that being is because he has what we
could call kind of a traditionally
handsome face shape it's rectangular
it's square and that's always a really
complimentary thing other square face
shapes that are considered kind of
classic hollywood handsome or guys like
james cagney or
even leonardo dicaprio so these guys
have this kind of look that is really
complemented by square shapes and as
soon as the hair is shaved very very
short because of the shape of the head
on top they all tend to look just a
little bit round as much as it really
does suit his personality because he is
a really carefree laid-back kind of guy
i really don't think a beard is brad's
best look
into the early 2000s you can see that
once again brad is growing his hair out
longer i can only surmise that this is
for his role in the movie troy in which
he used parsley his own hair and
partially some prosthetic hair from the
makeup department but this is something
that i think is is just comfortable for
brad i think he does genuinely gravitate
towards slightly longer looks and it's a
bit of a fountain of youth for him and i
think we can get into that in a minute
2007 is the first time he steps out with
angelina jolie on a red carpet and the
two of them just oozed that classic
hollywood charm it's really interesting
also to note that in 2007 was the advent
of the show mad men which became a
cultural icon of its own the references
that they made to the cool slick styles
of the early 1960s permeated fashion and
a lot of guys were trying to pull their
best don draper slick with a side part
and this is a look that brad pulls off
perfectly it is absolutely made for his
face shape because these classic looking
hairstyles have a little bit more of a
square construction and are incredibly
flattering to a square jaw so this for
me is probably one of my favorites and
at the time there was kind of ashton
kutcher surfy socal moppy kind of
hairstyle versus the don draper kind of
hipster old school set where a lot of
guys were going for that really old
vintage look just like grandpa used to
wear this was starting to take over so
brad pitt started off in 2007 like that
but you can see in 2008 the following
year he made a little bit of nod to the
biebs this little side swept bang in
this moppy bullish top going back to a
more modern military film for brad pitt
meant having shorter more military spec
hair so when he filmed in glorious
bastards in 2009
you can really see the influence of that
1940s era where everybody's hair was
kept very nice and short and clean you
can also see the influence in his facial
hair at the time in the 1940s a finely
groomed mustache would have been
considered something of clean kind of
upper-class society but wearing it past
filming was a bold choice because most
people didn't consider mustaches in
fashion at that point something that has
changed in just the last few years where
mustaches have now become very cool even
to this day i still see people coming in
with pictures of brad pitt from this
role as their mustache influence i think
the thing i like about this look is that
it still goes back to that old hollywood
vibe it is very dapper leading man and
it's really complementary to his face
shape and his general persona the 1950s
was all about rock and roll guys like
elvis presley johnny cash jerry lee
lewis they all started growing their
hair out longer into a style called the
pompadour which is what brad has in this
photo i think it's fascinating that
coming out of a world war ii movie brad
followed the exact same path as a lot of
the xgis did coming out of world war ii
where they're growing their hair longer
and into a more rock and roll savvy
style
[Music]
as the hair grows a little bit longer
too brad starts to express himself
through facial hair goatees are usually
for guys that are trying to elongate
their face shape so when you take
somebody with a square face shape or a
square jawline add a goatee to it to
elongate it even more it becomes less
flattering the longer it gets i'm not
going to call brad out for growing his
facial hair i mean let the guy do what
he wants how many times does this guy
have to win sexiest man alive for us to
just give him a hall pass on one thing
you can see now heading closer into the
20 teens that the hair is getting longer
again he did something that was very
popular called ombre and it's meant to
have a very seamless kind of sun-kissed
kind of look to the hair rather than
some of the more bolder color statements
he was making in the 90s this was a lot
more subtle and a lot more natural and
if you ask me just looks a lot more
mature even though i think that his long
hair gives him a certain kind of
fountain of youth quality here and i
think that's what he really likes about
the long hair is it keeps him very young
and very casual feeling once again after
a period of growing out a little bit of
comfort brad changes his hair
drastically for a role as a tank
commander in the movie fury this took
what was already a simmering style trend
of these old school classic haircuts and
it poured gasoline on it as soon as
everybody saw this movie or even just
saw the movie poster guys were flooding
into barber shops asking for this
hairstyle it probably helped that also
similar to his style as seen in the show
peaky blinders and so when it comes to
a movie role like this for brad pitt
being able to commit to that
authenticity of those looks was really
great because even though it inspired
all these beautiful fades and really
clean classic backward flowing haircuts
the haircut itself looked like it had
been done with a pair of hand clippers
in the back of a tank in world war ii he
just went with what was authentic and i
really admire that about it it was
absolutely a huge huge fashion trend and
fury is probably going to go down as one
of his most iconic roles in 2019 film
once upon a time in hollywood was the
story of the golden age of hollywood in
1969 so of course brad got to grow his
hair back out for a very fitting role as
a stuntman in that film and it was
absolutely perfectly on point this is in
fact transitioning away from that mad
men era into more of that 70s grown out
kind of longer shapes that a lot of guys
were wearing so he really again hit a
completely authentic look with this one
but i think it also came a little bit
more in line with how he feels most
comfortable this guy just can't lose he
looks amazing with long hair he looks
amazing with short hair and as soon as
you put him in a tuxedo on a runway or
somewhere in red carpet for an award
show everybody's just flooding in asking
for these shapes what i really like
about him though is he's his own man
he's always doing his own thing even
with those slight dalliances and those
tiny little like influences from like
don draper or even justin bieber you
know you still get to see brad through
it all his personality really shines
through all those looks and it's there
is a bit of a consistency to his vibe
even though the hairstyles are
drastically different there just is a
comfort to it you know and to me that's
a guy that looks entirely comfortable in
his own skin well if you made it this
far in the video you clearly like brad
pitt as much as i do but if there's
anyone else that you think we should
take a deep dive into write them in the
comments below maybe i'll have a look
[Music]